en deçà d'un marché commun les anglais
n'aiment pas aller 1973 le royaume uni
entre dans la communauté économique
européenne
pour madame white et de nombreux
britanniques c'est vraiment sans
enthousiasme c'est le gouvernement
lui-même pas toujours privilégier sa
souveraineté plutôt que de soutenir le
projet européen
en 1988 le discours de bruges marque le
refus de l'europe fédérale
la première ministre conservatrice
margaret thatcher met les points sur les
i nous n'avons pas réussi à faire
reculer l'état en grande bretagne pour
nous le voir à poser de nouveau au
niveau européen avec un super état
exerçant sa domination à partir de
bruxelles décembre 1991 à maastricht
la grande bretagne refuse d'union
monétaire et l'europe sociale
deux chantiers ambitieux ouvert par
l'union européenne john mayer le nouveau
premier ministre britannique rassure
ainsi des eurosceptiques de son parti il
a réussi lors des négociations à
maintenir coûte que coûte la
souveraineté britannique
le premier ministre conservateur rentrer
à londres réjouit de ne pas avoir cédé
sur l'irruption de contraintes
communautaire nouvelle dans la vie des
entreprises britanniques en 1995
rebelote londres dit non à la zone
schengen lorsque l'europe ouvre ses
frontières
la grande-bretagne craintes au contraire
de ne plus pouvoir contrôler les siennes
britanniques et irlandais refuse cette
convention de schengen donnée d'or l'a
rappelé en février dernier il ne fait
confiance qu'à scotland yard
pareil pour la monnaie commune en 2002
la grande-bretagne n'adopte pas l'euro
le premier ministre tony blair ya songé
mais la population britannique ne veut
pas elle n'a pas confiance dans une
monnaie dirigé depuis bruxelles et elle
est très attaché sentimentalement à sa
monnaie est content de garder la ville
les institutions financières sont sans
doute favorable à l'euro à blé mais la
population n'en veut pas enfin en 2011
la grande bretagne dit non au traité
budgétaire
cette année là la crise économique
frappe la zone euro pour y mettre fin
la france et l'allemagne proposent un
traité qui va plus loin dans
l'intégration économique et budgétaire
de lieux mais pour londres
cette réforme est perçue comme une
menace contre les privilèges de la city
c'est le clash
puisqu'on ne peut pas obtenir les garde
fous et que nous voulions à l'intérieur
du traité il vaut mieux rester en dehors
c'est le royaume uni se retrouve
complètement isolés sur la scène
européenne
le référendum sur son maintien dans l'ue
a fini par s'imposer
le 23 juin 2016 les britanniques votent
à 51 9 9% pour le breakbeat
[Musique]